now we've watched the ukrainian people
fight for their lives with the
resilience and resolves astounded the
rest of the world
and it's the ukrainian leaders who've
led by example the boxing klitschko
brothers have been on the ground
shoulder-to-shoulder with their
countrymen showing great determination
to defend their country against putin's
army this is before we came on air i
spoke to former world heavyweight
champion vladimir klitschko from kiev in
ukraine where his brother vitali is the
mayor
it was one of those interviews where
when i'd finished i said to the team
we've got to run every single word of
that because i found it so uniquely
powerful
so we are
here it is the whole interview
completely uncentered from start to
finish and i started by asking vladimir
klitschko this is the most important
fight of his life
i would
say that this battle is definitely
the most important
of our lives
of the ukrainians
when they were
expecting to be attacked as as it
happened on 24th of february
and this senseless war
has
taken
thousands of
lives
destroyed infrastructure in the country
and still going on the fights are still
going on while we're talking
and every night every day there are
rocket attacks up to 2 000 rockets had
been launched from belarus and russia
to destroy our life
life of ukrainians that were
associating themselves with
democratic values
of the free world
and we
have committed us to it
since 2014
and the world
totally
underestimated
the annexation of crimea by russia
support of the
lugansk and doneks
so-called separatists
and
continuing
with invasion
of the entire country
russia needs
ukraine obviously
as we see but russia doesn't need
ukrainians and that's why
civilians are getting killed
and residential
districts in the cities being bombed
with phosphoric bombs and
cluster bombing
which is continuing
that was
in
butcher gesture in macariff
all those satellite cities were acting
like a shield
for the
capital of ukraine
and they were taking the first hit
i was in bucha
i saw it with my own eyes
all the civilians that been
tortured with the tight hands behind
their head
and behind their back and with a shot in
the hat executed
there's so many children that been
suffering
killed or injured up to 1 000 children
we can't really
give exact numbers because the numbers
are still going on and counting
and
the world just has underestimated this
madman's man
aggression
and now
as the consequence and i remember those
lines from the world leaders
saying
if russia is going to cross the line and
invade ukraine they're going to be
consequences and those consequences for
almost two months
we were taken the ukraine has been taken
eventually
now the free world is openly supporting
us
with defensive weapons with the weapons
period
in the war you cannot fight with bare
knuckles
we need weapons to protect our sky above
our heads
and protect our home country
and the war is reckless
and i couldn't even imagine in my life
that
any other human can do something like
that to the other human
and that's what i've seen in bucha
but the repetition of buche is in
multiple cities in the country
so this genocide of the ukrainian
population must be stopped and this is
not the word that the world
should be scared of even think about it
or pronounce it it is
happening
in ukraine
it is happening
mariupol has been destroyed completely
and
we just
hope
and do anything for it so that this war
is going to be stopped
with the help of the free world and i
want to use just one one moment of of
of this monologue
and say thank you to great britain
boris johnson
that has stepped in he was trying a lot
from the early beginning
to find
the way how he can talk
to putin how he can prevent the first
steps that unfortunately were made and
the lines were crossed
and all the support and supply that
we were receiving from the
beginning and this is so great
to have allies and partners
of our nation i just want to say thank
you and i want to say please don't stop
supporting us as long as this war is
still going because
our economy is down to nothing
we
we have great will
and we stand strong with our will
against one of the strongest armies in
the world but our will is stronger than
any army or any weapon
and we
show it
we're dedicated
to the country to freedom
in ukraine in europe and in the world
because from this war
not just ukraine is suffering the entire
europe and the world is suffering
the prices are going to go up
the
gas prices food prices so everything
is connected with each other in this
world we're
living
in a global world
and we're very very connected with each
other
and
it is very important to keep this chain
connected if ukraine
fails you're gonna fail two guys
well i mean i mean that's one of the
most powerful
openings
to an interview i think i've probably
ever done in my life
the passion the eloquence
the resilience in your voice the
determination
ultimately
were 82 or three days into this war now
putin clearly felt he could just run
over ukraine and seize it
uh that's failed
but he's waged this genocidal rampage
through your country
i guess the big question now is can
ukraine
win
can you can you actually defeat
vladimir putin
we didn't start this war obviously
we're taking the consequences
we
cannot plan
for the next minute our day
we need support that partially we're
getting
we determine
we are determined
to protect
ourselves our families our children
our parents
that are with us or buried in this
ground this is our home
there is not even a doubt
we don't ask ourselves can we win it
this is our home you do anything for
your family
for your children
anything
to protect
to cover
to give future
to be more creative and not destructive
and that's what ukrainians are
we are
creative
we're great at
aviation
if think about just first helicopter
that was launched a couple of hundreds
of meters from here
in the city by igor sikorsky
we prob probably you know it's not
advertising but in i.t area we're we're
great and uh you're probably using
what's up and it was created by
ukrainian jan kuhn
originally from vinitza
so and we can
endlessly count on and on
we are
well educated we're giving to the world
we're not taking yes we ask a lot about
help and support now
but we were giving a lot too and we will
give more
trust me
one of the most extraordinary things uh
vladimir one of the most extraordinary
things about
this war
is the way it's played out in real time
on social media we've all been able to
watch the horror as it's unfurl but
we've also been able to watch people
like you and your brother vitali who's
the mayor of kiev and of course
president zielenski and and the strange
curiosity about the three of you is that
two of you are former professional
boxers
and one was a comedian and yet you've
come to symbolize the astonishing
resilience of the ukrainian people
where do you get that from
you and your brother is it from
your childhood is it from your father
who was a pilot with the soviet uh air
force and who uh had to go in after
chernobyl and that in the end uh cost
him his life
is that where you get this strength from
we were you from a very early age
effectively shown how to fight for your
country and how to
survive this kind of thing
look i i'm not gonna talk a lot about my
brother myself because i believe there
are women and men that right now
standing in the front line and
protecting our country and have lost
their lives as well
and i have lots of respect um
for all the ukrainians that doing
for the past 83 days what we've been
doing and
obviously you understand it's like in in
economy entrepreneurship and
entrepreneurship so you understand that
your piece of a big bigger puzzle and
the big puzzle
actually exists and functions from small
pieces like you
and i i do know that and remember as we
as we uh all are probably those famous
lines don't ask what you
what country can do for you ask what
they can do for your country and
obviously
i asked myself i could be with my child
somewhere in the safety and um and just
probably
my child is the most important thing in
my life but i also understood that
there is much bigger things
and freedom and your people and your
country and
and basically this connection that
you're part of this big puzzle
and
you need to stay connected especially in
these challenging times and not just
challenging this is the times of war
who would have thought in 2022 well just
recently we're looking at
elon musk and um nasa
ships
exploring mars and i could take a look
from my tesla you know about the weather
on mars and who would have thought that
someone else is going to collect land
and say this is our land we need more
land it's not enough land and
create something that exists in in just
one person's mind and its effectiveness
and populism is definitely needs to be
reconsidered in the world because
propaganda and populism is leading to
something like we have as a result now
but that's for the time after the war
obviously and been always like that it's
been always like that the beginning and
the end of anything
and the war as well
are you prepared to the time after the
war yeah but it's it's eventually gonna
happen and and
we we definitely need to the world must
learn from this senseless aggression
that is happening now again after second
world war are you prepared if it comes
to it to
lose your life to fight for your country
i asked mike
myself this question when russian forces
were in outskirts of the city
and if i wouldn't be ready for it i
would have left
the city of kiev with almost 5 million
people like a sponge
its big city and busy city was empty
you could hear the explosions
constant
explosion because the fights were going
on in the outskirts of the city
and
you must count with anything while
you're in cave or in ukraine with
anything
even now and this question is basically
everyone in ukraine ukrainian or not and
as you know their journalists your
colleagues journalists been killed
precisely with sniper shots
and lost their lives if you're in
ukraine you must
you must know that that could be your
last moment in life
last trip in life and
are you ready to give up anything you
have for the country and freedom
and that's the question that
millions of ukraine's asking and the
answer is yes because you could do
anything for your children anything for
your country anything for your parents
anything that
that you love
and
that's something that just
cannot be in a different in a different
way
what is your message to putin
i've been asked this question many times
in multiple occasions and interviews
it's
just
you know
there's no particular
line that
could do anything
to put him to change his life
or to a person in this case
and change his opinion or or stop this
war
it's just in mad person's mind and how
you can convince a madman i don't even
know
and there is nothing to communicate
because obviously what was coming from
russian side
is a lie
when they said we're never gonna
offend anyone invade anyone it was just
happening
and this is in multiple cases
as soon as
russia put him his army or foreign
ministers or anybody involved
were making statements
that was exactly the opposite
so how can we communicate i don't see
even sense or reason
there is just
one
line
that
not just putin but
the entire world
must take it seriously
stop
this
senseless
war and this is on putin
and as well as on the free world because
without you support and help and if
you're gonna keep
standing silently
and just observing what is going on in
ukraine blood is on your hands too
because you do nothing about it
if you do nothing about it and that's
why stale out
to stop
this war
i'm not going to get into details but
stop this war
as soon as the war is going to be
stopped
life's going to be saved
no emotion what is what is your view
of what should be done for example
with russian sports
people uh athletes and so on there is a
view that they should all be banned from
any competition there's another view
that only the team
playing under the russian flag should be
banned and individuals should be allowed
to continue what is your view as one of
the great
sporting champions certainly in my
lifetime
on economical side
isolation of russia
on different
points of it gas oil coal
no ships can park at any ports
they should understand that the world is
against
this senseless war
against
not just with warding and sanctions but
in reality nothing but isolation at
least
next olympic games i think
that iuc should ban
the russian team now
the war is going on
they cannot participate in the next
olympic games they cannot participate in
any
athletic events
because
this war
is represented by russia
so atlas representing russia and there
is definitely connection and i believe
that this is going to be the message and
that's exactly the answer for the
question what would you say to mr putin
it's really saying is cheap now
action speaks louder than words
isolation
isolation and this isolation speaks
louder than any line
in any word
because isolation is painful
yes it's going to be painful for
athletes it's going to be painful for
economy it's going to be painful for
everybody and anybody that is involved
with russia
silently
trading with russia
supporting their financially with this
in this trade because the money that
russia is getting and filling up their
budget
they're getting and producing more
weapons and financing their soldiers
that today killing us ukrainians
and that must be stopped with isolation
and atlas is not an exception
vladimir when this war is over and one
day it will be over
do you hope to
get back to boxing again there's been
lots of speculation that that may be
what you want to do
you're going to put smile on my face i i
just realized recently that they haven't
smiled a lot in the past
80
to 3 days and
you just said something about sports
because that puts me in somewhere my
comfort zone because that's where my
passion is and
and honestly i was i was thinking like i
should i should just
take tyson fury and tweet
last dance question mark
since he wants to retire and we
and we uh we supposed to have this
rematch and then and i was thinking
about it you know i didn't do it because
my mind was in totally different
or now a different world but it just you
know after
getting those news that um he defended
the title and he is
retiring and i wish him the best
uh but i was really thinking i should i
should send this i should tweet this
last dance you feel like it's uh do you
feel like it's unfinished business with
you too
i believe i believe uh well that was
that was all the dreams before the war
and i was i was um sharing those dreams
i had a dream to become the oldest
heavyweight champion of the world and
not
to
break the jaw
in the ring
you know
obviously speaking
um
of the contra hand but
to break the record
break the record and that's to become
the oldest saveway champion after uh
george foreman um so i was 45 now i'm 46
and that's exactly the time that was the
plan but uh we we're talking about
something that was happening before and
now there's a big question mark what is
going to
go on with the war and
and
there's a lot of question marks we don't
know what is going to happen tomorrow so
that's why i think that's right but i
also think
i loved your reaction when i mentioned
it because it must be
it must be hellish what you're all going
through in ukraine and the moment i
mentioned something which took you back
to your life before this your face lit
up you know the last time i saw you
was at the alfred dunhill links golf
tournament in october last year
and i remember you you were celebrating
one night with andre chefchenko the the
great ukrainian football player
and life seemed pretty good for all of
us right then and life has changed very
dramatically now and i very much hope
that you know come
the autumn this war is over
you've got your country back you've won
and i get to see you again up in
scotland on the links there because that
would be a sign
of i think a reward for the astonishing
courage that you and the ukrainian
people have shown
fingers crossed
hopefully the peace in ukraine will
come sooner than later
thank you for hanging me
mr morgan it was great seeing you you
know what it's just from tv ukraine
it's been such an honor to interview i'm
in total awe of all that you're doing uh
and all the ukrainian people we all are
over here and i think the more that
britain can do and the more the west can
do generally to help you defeat putin
the better and i will be urging them to
do that and i wish you and your family
all the very best uh vladimir as you go
forward
and i just hope that you continue
continue to confound all the
the skeptics and the doubters and that
you win this war because it matters so
much i think to democracy that you do
thank you
thank you for having me
you